[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
May 1st I'm Danny Lewis for the Wall
Street Journal filling in for J.R Whalen
acting right now can be really tricky
given High interest rates inflation and
fluctuations in the stock market
so a lot of people are turning to
long-term options in hopes of writing
out any instability
one of those are certificates of deposit
according to the Federal Reserve
balances and CDs swell to more than 480
billion dollars in February up from 36.5
billion this time last year and even
those are still subject to interest rate
changes so if you decide to go that
route what's the best way to do it here
now to discuss is oyan adedoyan from the
wsj's personal finance team oh and
simple question here what is a
certificate of deposit also known as a
CD
a CD D is a super safe asset that
basically pays out interest over a set
of time so say an individual an investor
wants to put a certain amount of money
away for a long period of time with a
guaranteed interest level that it's
going to gain over that time they would
use a CD to lock their money away for
maybe say anywhere from six months to
five years and then be promised that at
the end of that date they would have a
certain amount of money gained why are
certificates of deposit so attractive to
invest in right now they're attractive
to invest because of the high interest
rates so the Federal Reserve has been
increasing rates incrementally in an
effort to curb inflation and so CDs are
at some of the highest interest rates
that they've been in 15 years Financial
analysts say now what does it mean for
someone to set up a CD ladder can you
walk me through what that might look
like so a CD ladder is a little bit more
complicated and it's less of a device to
optimize your yield and more of a device
to kind of take advantage of high yields
that are existing right now because some
of the highest yields on CDs are more
short term an investor might want to
spread their money out over a longer
period of time to both take advantage of
short-term yields but still have money
parked away for the longer term so say
example you have thirty thousand dollars
to invest you want to make sure the
money is available every six months or
so just have flexibility you can set up
a CD where you put ten thousand in a six
month CD another ten thousand a one year
CD and another 10 000 in a three year CD
and those would have varying interest
rates so why might Savers want to invest
in CDs over other stable investment
options like five-year treasury notes I
bonds or even just sticking cash in a
savings account yeah it really just
depends on the individual investor but
basically CDs are in a place right now
where they are comparable to rates that
you can get from an i Bond or a treasury
and in some cases CDs are actually
outpacing treasuries when it comes to
yields especially for the short term so
someone who wants to take advantage of a
high yield but still maintain a
relatively safe investment since CDs are
known to be on the safer side I would
want to consider this types of savings
accounts who would benefit the most from
CD ladders CD ladders are usually most
beneficial for folks like retirees who
are kind of living on a fixed income
every month and so they want to maybe
stretch that money over the long term
are there any downsides to investing in
CDs yeah there are some downsides you
definitely want to watch out for CDs
that are callable and that means that
the issuer has the ability to return
your cash early and Skip on the
remaining interest payment so you're not
going to get that full interest that you
were promised early on when you signed
on to the CD so you want to make sure
that you're avoiding those types of CDs
and you also want to make sure that you
are avoiding withdrawing early from a CD
because the penalty for taking that
money out early could be anywhere from
three to six months of Interest so if
someone wants to start climbing a CD
ladder what should they look for when
deciding where to start they should
definitely look for a CD that is FDIC
insured to make sure that all their
money up to 250 000 is protected and
they should also monitor the difference
between a CD that's brokered and a CD
that's from the bank if you buy a bank
CD and you need the money before reaches
maturity then you'll probably have to
pay that early withdrawal fee that we
were talking about however with
brokerage CDs they can be sold penalty
free so so you want to really weigh all
your options and right now kind of with
access the internet it's easier than
ever to have a wide array of options for
CDs that's oyan adedoyan from the wsj
personal finance team and that's your
money briefing I'm Danny Lewis for the
Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]